so your husband though he just Chris
Pratt he had a birthday right everybody
what job get him I got him piggies you
got him actual pigs yeah I like
miniature ones no actually what happened
to me when I was in high school was I
rescued this supposed miniature Pig Oh
when I lived at my parents house and it
turned into a giant pot-bellied pig and
rooted up my mom's entire lawn I'm just
laughing because if nobody's actually
had a huge but very enormous they're so
big very very large yeah that's bacon my
pig my little brother Christopher
actually named her bacon so it's his
fault but yeah he has we have an amazing
place in Washington State so there's a
lot of land there so the pigs are not
living with us yeah they're living in a
very beautiful farm yeah loving life
very large now so I'm very excited that
they did not come to our house because I
was told they would say small they did
not yeah I was told my dog was gonna be
miniature and lies and heifers like 45
pounds I'm like what he is not 15 to 18
pounds
that's awesome those y'all have a farm
in Washington Washington's beautiful
yeah yes nice place to escape that's
yeah yeah I grew up around animals so
it's really fun and I did as well I love
it yeah it makes me so happy animals are
so cool they're just loyal and nice and
they're never mean so have y'all ever
had any unusual pets my I just had this
babysitter and she had a rooster oh and
I mean yeah that's the thing yeah it was
very mean yeah she would go outside and
she loved the rooster because how can
you not love animals and she would go
outside and try to bond with it and it
would try to bite her yeah and out a
certain point it was chasing her all
around the yard and she climbed up a
tree and it bit her butt and it was
horrible oh my god that happened to me
one time in a little petting zoo my
sister I was holding her child in this
goat kept it nipping in my behind I was
like get that job
because I was holding your kid like firm
to go and like my sister's just laughing
and I'm like it's eating my bobs like
anyway subscribe to my channel subscribe
to my channel subscribe to my channel
subscribe to my channel please don't
make me keep going